how's it going bros my name is paulo
whoa
sorry I just need I needed to wake up a
little bit it's really late but that's
the perfect time to play some horror
games but I bet you're thinking
minecraft let's say a horror game hey
right but it's a mod of PT which I don't
know if you remember is it's the silent
hill's demo which is terrifying as [ __ ]
and to combine that with minecraft ah
the [ __ ] is going on not an inch or
something what the [ __ ] are you
it's not a little baby hey little baby
oh god I'm sorry the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
I don't want to go out there I want to
play with a little oh my god what's
happening
yes just right guy [ __ ] parents won a
demon baby from space there what the
[ __ ] are you doing get away no shame
there you go ah no stupid night for
[ __ ] sake hey Feist okay [ __ ] you I
can't jump this is really weird
huh I can't [ __ ] be scared in
Minecraft that's just kind of sad a bit
alright well that's kind of scary
well you look hot I haven't wet see I
like oh my god
and I remember that audio they ripped it
off so [ __ ] creepy
it freaked me the [ __ ] out when he
played in Swedish such genius oh there's
my character hey how does it go father
went to the trunk of his car
retrieved a rifle and shot his wife she
was cleaning up the kitchen after God
this is really a detail I hear what
they're collecting I don't know I don't
know minecraft like I don't [ __ ] know
how it works but let's go no right
that's all right uh well uh first of all
holy [ __ ] so I would actually put a lot
of effort if it is second of all I don't
think I supposed to be here how the how
the [ __ ] do I get back I don't want to
be here ah I broke my leg Oh teleport
you sorry seriously oh wait I can do
that what the [ __ ] I'm so confused cuz I
don't know minecraft and I'm just like
what the [ __ ] is going our admission if
Matthew McConaughey was here right now
he'd be holding me so tight don't die
now don't die don't die oh god I think I
almost died I think I fell down the
stairs slice I'm in broke my neck there
we go that was fine oh cool Oh Geoff
bloody fun spit die Geoff la bola Robin
why would he stop it's really loud in my
headphones can you [ __ ] all right you
know what
all right you freaking with the [ __ ] out
stop
no no ghosts aren't real no no it's now
go he don't die that was fun let's not
do that again
the [ __ ] this is [ __ ] I am sweating
balls ready out of that - oh my god
you're gonna break yet you're gonna
break scared I can feel the stress
inside me it's not what's not good
someone's breathing that's not bad
don't let that [ __ ] you my graft this is
terrifying
[ __ ] you there was another family shot
to death oh my god muffin it's really
late I can't stream like this stop stop
how about the [ __ ] I'm just getting to
talk to push hi bish hey Darin air hey
bet
swish me at my side Bush got damn it
right out right all right
the [ __ ] is still there you know oh no
yeah yeah oh my god this is an awesome
mod I gotta say but [ __ ] hell is it
over yet you know it's a good heart of
it when you just wanted to end nice
light luckily I was take care of your
baby care if you're ugly as [ __ ] worketh
or load o Lord of Darkness
I was lucky on my chat got my child
you can't just tap the one
I can't a bass alright it's my baby
[ __ ] off oh my god first you want to get
out then you want to get in make up your
damn man
thank you thanks I like how they made
this one not impossible to be this one
like to get this point in the original
will take you like 20 minutes
hello oh my god my voice oh my god
this needs to dis Dorit story thing in
eats please Anna needs a shot to
homicide to be [ __ ] related though it
could be my loading I don't know this is
Jo my hair and other I don't feel
anything feelings and family
Susu and so no mayo vendor ding I need
to get my scene here
she doesn't speak French but I need to
need some moral support all right
don't touch that dial now we're just
getting started
that's what she said ah wall I'm in head
amended oh sorry I have a alright no big
deal I just nearly [ __ ] near died
from glass window squared
god damn there's an ugly couple look at
that poor man he met look what he
married that's an ugly [ __ ] right there
not I mean she may have been great
personalities
we don't know I don't judge for
appearances like see I kissed her even
though she's ugly as [ __ ] I don't judge
her for being ugly my god oh my god
chill the [ __ ] out
i order a badger at least i think they
were deliveries dead [ __ ] hell he can
can even collect badgers these days
started 20 yeah there's something on the
floor what is this
what's going on e very very suspicious
how it's dangling now that's what she
said Oh walk all right your your Lord of
Darkness badger goddamn it
never move his step alright I don't but
the Badger was not supposed to talk to
me telepathically alright that's another
thing I ordered with the Badger and why
did he come in such a huge ass box how
big is his box badger
all right well go back to hell badger go
back to hell
Badgers never listen I don't know why I
even try ridiculous
well if you don't know then you don't
know no wait if you don't know I had a
good quote Oh God what's that mean I
hear someone walking Oh God where's eat
anything it's not a tomato sauce you
want to spend you mean gross sulfur til
you've emptied a famous game I feel fat
anonymous people so passionately another
ticket don't go you're all my family
before you say hey yeah I got this part
wow it's so long you got fired so you
drown your sorrows in booze don't tell
me what to do [ __ ] huh don't tell me
put something on this part we're so hard
to figure out like you had to look
through the wall I think you can't trust
it at water that sounds like conspiracy
theory and that sounds like someone
who's not got the [ __ ] together it so I
ain't got [ __ ] only reasoning she should
earn a wage at a ball is the manager
like how she look in a skirt well what
about me I look fantastic in a skirt
that's it that's a really [ __ ] weird
thing to say you know so you remember
right exactly ten months big this is so
[ __ ] tricky I feel like I'm on drugs
it's not making me sick up oh cool I
like that he fixed someone that what I
would say we're just kind of annoying
like if you get stuck in a horror game
you just get annoyed it doesn't add to
the immersion in why the breaks the
immersion so I don't understand why they
made it so hard
the original PT I don't know this is my
opinion uh why is it so bright here are
we in the bright though I think
Oh [ __ ] oh no no no no here we are
it's this facade please be facade Oh God
what is sad mr. phone isn't it oh hey
when I'm taking my darling love you so
much have my babies
oh yeah sound all gone
oh yeah oh alright alright you know what
I feel is a poisonous
Oh sick
77082 studio hello Oh [ __ ] the gap in
the door it's a separate man
and walk all right box getting tired of
your [ __ ] but welcome warmly for a
marvel [ __ ] hell it's so [ __ ]
creepy hey I wasn't even scared is that
all you got
you think that's gonna scare me I got
enough to push baby to take care of I've
been through it all
thanks Kate it's getting me pay just
take me home please don't don't don't me
[ __ ] I'll don't you I told I'd
literally just told you don't tell me
[ __ ]
oh yeah you can see here I remember that
you can see here at one point up there
so creepy oh [ __ ] every day the same
kind of food dress the same gym bar the
same kind of game yeah he's just that
kind of guy
then one day he goes and killed us all
up couldn't even be original about the
wait I'm not complaining I was dying for
it in any way first a girl a boy I will
be going
bringing my new toys with me there it is
the original Silent Hill theme as well
the nostalgia Lyndhurst elgyn beautiful
I'm gonna pause there uh I have so many
thoughts going on right now that was
such a cool mod I am very impressed by
whoever made it because it really
captured the soul of PT and if you
haven't played it before uh it kind of
played as if you played it before cuz I
didn't drag out a lot of parts which I
really really liked I could just breathe
great pacing I guess is my point uh
super cool super impressed if you
haven't if you don't really understand
what I'm talking about when I talk about
PT I made a video of it so I'll live it
in description check it out and it's so
cool you can't play the game anymore
unfortunately uh let me give a little
bit of background PT came out which was
a playable teaser for free on
PlayStation 4 and then once he finished
it it was announced that it they
announced the title of silent hill's
there hasn't been a proper Silent Hill
game in such a long time because his
studios has been taken over by western
studios instead of Japanese studios and
everyone knows Japanese studios just a
lot better so Kojima came back and he's
he he's working on the silent hill's and
obviously so excited because just a
playable teaser was [ __ ] amazing but
then something happened I don't know
what and they took the game off from
PlayStation 4 and then later announced
that the game is not gonna be released
it's such a [ __ ] disappointment cuz
it looked like this could be like the
first proper triple-a title horror game
since I would say siren siren blood
curse um I can't think of one honestly
so such a disappointment but it's still
I really enjoyed playing this so the
huge thanks to whoever made it and leave
in the description if you wanna check it
out yourself bro so if you enjoyed
watching that was a great time to leave
it like I'll see you in the next one is
always stay awesome bros